[Music]
well there's nobody who didn't have a
horrible high school experience except
for like one guy I met once
I thought I'll make a show about high
school that's a horror movie
just as my high school was and that's
something that I really wanted to talk
about I knew there would be a lot of fun
there when you read that pilot you know
there was something special there was
something different there I was
originally cast as Cornelia and I would
have done this as a lesser role at that
point because jaws had something it's
not just just vampires and you know
running around being crazy this there's
a lot of humor and intelligence in the
writing jobs there are two things that I
don't believe in coincidence and
leprechauns which we just write what we
love to please ourselves and and that
some of that is childish and some of it
is hopefully very intelligent there's
nobody we're saying oh they won't get
this I mean I'm hoping there's something
in there for everybody okay but I was
writing about leprechauns right oh no no
I'm in love with this I just you know I
love these actors I love these
characters I there's so many stories
about these people I want to tell when
did you die you never told me it was
just for a few minutes we all have to
take orders from everybody when we're
teenagers and here's somebody who yeah
her mom tells a dependent for a room
yeah our teachers tell her to do her
homework but at the in the end of the
day she gets to go save the world and we
all like to think that we could
[Music]
you